now less than four months ago Sam Jimmer
announced on this program that he will
be running to be leader of the
Conservative Party but after having the
conservative whip withdrawn for voting
against the government
last night he announced that he was
joining the Liberal Democrats and he
joins us now from his new party's
conference in Bournemouth thank you for
being on the program today Thank You
Sophie well you've been on a hell of a
journey since we last had you on the
program
when you were on the show last you
actually said during the course of my
political life I've been mistaken for a
Labour MPs and would now say a Lib Dem
but I'm now I'm a dyed-in-the-wool
conservative so what's changed since
then well I think's I think that's a
very good question to ask I mean when I
entered the leadership race I said I
wanted to broaden the race in terms of
ideas I wanted to help focus the
Conservative Party on the valleys that
have made it successful historically and
I also wanted reality in the brexit
debate and during the course of that
contest it became very clear that there
are too few people like me in the party
who stand up for those values the party
is you know has done something
unprecedented it's withdrawing the whip
from moderate and MPs I resigned from a
ministerial job because of brexit and
the stark reality was that I had to face
the fact that the Conservative Party is
in a different place and if I want to
fight in politics for liberal values
that millions of people want to see in
our politics then the Conservative Party
is no longer the place to do so so yes
it's a hell of a journey in terms of the
fact that I was in the party for 20
years I've got long-standing friends and
I believe I was evangelical about the
Conservative Party haven't come from
what many would say is a non traditional
conservative backgrounds but I've been
consistent have been consistent in the
sense that with brexit we have to go
back to the people now that we know is
negotiable I was willing to leave a job
on that basis I was consistent in voting
against no deal even though I was
threatened
with having the whip removed and I'm
consistent insane okay if that is where
we are this is where I can do my
politics rather than just rub along in
the Conservative Party because I want to
protect my seat so you just said there
that you've been consistent in saying we
should go back to the people so in that
case if the Lib Dem position at the end
of conference is to actually just revoke
article 50 rather than having a second
referendum will you leave the Lib Dems
as well that's not the position the
position is if the Liberal Democrats
were to win a general election their
policy would be to revoke article 53 cuz
where the patient comes like a
revocation would be on condition that
the British public have overwhelmingly
voted for a liberal democratic
government and if you vote for a
government you'd say they should
implement the policy so that's that's
that's what they will be doing but the
party is still supporting a people's
vote as a way to break the bricks it
deadlock now many of you many people on
your program and the conservative side
would say that is anti-democratic but
they want a slap election to take it
back to the people the truth is both of
them are a referendum in all but name
the problem with a general election
though is you muddy breaks it with lots
of other domestic issues if you want to
resolve brexit the best way to do it is
to have the people's vote now that we
all know what is negotiable I just want
to ask a question from one of our
viewers because you of course are still
the MP for sorry east you lasted as a
conservative in that seat and I just was
contacted this morning by a man called
Lee Lomas he said can you are Sam why
I'm now represented by a party that
gained 10 percent of the votes
well the EBU could say the party gained
10 percent a vote that the party did
incredibly well in the European
elections the brexit party got 10,000
votes in Easter in the European
elections the Liberal Democrats got
7,000 votes in the European elections so
the since 2017 public opinion has
shifted somewhat in Ysera but there will
be an election we all know very soon and
I will decide what I do
then but I am I am still the Member of
Parliament very serene if your member
was to contact me I would serve them as
I serve all my constituents I have never
undertaken casework for constituents
discriminating based on who they voted
for I do my best to serve them as
constituents rather than which party
they come from you say that you're still
thinking about where to stand at the
election is there a chance that you
might fight in the same seat that you're
in now there is every chance nothing has
been decided you ask me other start you
know kind of well you know a lot has
happened in a very short space of time
and I think I've got to digest where we
end the discussions are yet to come